there's a layer to the office even the
most die-hard fans may be oblivious to
the many hours of deleted scenes that
never made it to prime time
some episodes have so many that they
nearly constitute separate episodes
under themselves
and many are just as funny as the jokes
we still quote endlessly
it's hard to forget michael fresh off
his trip to a jamaican resort
banging on a steel drum and serenading
his employees with the news that he's
feeling
[Applause]
that's all i know so far but i'm gonna
keep practicing it's good
he has no idea that he isn't introducing
his colleagues to island living
but preventing them from doing their
work and simultaneously no
idea that the sunbathing photo of jan is
about to blow up his office
in this deleted scene he's almost sweet
in his sincerity
michael sounds ridiculous as he attempts
to remember the lyrics to harry
belafonte's deo
and no he's nowhere near pulling off
this vibe
he describes wanting every day to feel
like he did for him in jamaica
when he woke with the sunrise ate a
mango and looked forward to hours spent
with someone he loved
michael has no idea how silly he looks
how messy things are about to get with
jan
and his job or how much he's going to
annoy his employees
he's just happy to be enjoying his
newfound sense of vacation identity
ryan's descent from good-natured temp to
sleazy pretentious grifter was one of
the office's most satisfying character
arcs
it's not that he was ever diabolical
just deeply and
unrelentingly smug even at the depths of
his low points
from sporting bleached hair in a bowling
alley to being driven to work by his mom
he never lost his grip on his own
unearned sense of superiority
audiences love to hate ryan because the
world is so full of ryan's
he tried on being a hipster photographer
the world's laziest startup mastermind
and even the dad dumping his baby on a
stranger to follow
an unendingly codependent relationship
this deleted scene gives the viewer a
bit of insight into how ryan
rationalizes being ryan
as he explains to kevin someone else
does everything bad he's ever
perpetrated
and that guy is always and forever the
old ryan
he's ryan 2.0 now and now still has to
bear the weight of another man's
misdeeds
why should he be punished when the sins
of this other man already press down
upon him each day
it's utterly obnoxious and makes total
sense
plus it makes the moment when kevin
pulls the same trick on him all the more
sweet
jim and michael's relationship took many
forms like when jim confided in his
bumbling boss about his feelings for pam
it was a genuine friendship other times
it became a game of jim seeing just how
much he could get away with under the
nose of his boss
once in a while it grew openly
adversarial but it never stopped
mattering from the moment they were
introduced to the day michael left for
colorado
this deleted scene from local ad is an
example of the kindness that was always
the foundation of jim and michael's
camaraderie
yes jim is pulling a fast one on michael
culminating in michael's surrender of
his own office
michael is made to look silly in
contrast to jim's knowing prankster
charm
but jim is genuinely helping his friend
get into the right headspace
and by the end of the episode he
arranges a special screening of the
michael scott director's cut at poor
richard's pup
when michael needs a suit to play off
jim steps in to provide
michael meanwhile gives him a creative
outlet in his workday
perhaps the office's greatest trick was
its casting of real-life rock star creed
bratton as a fictionalized version of
himself
bratton's performance never entirely
strayed from the truth of his origins
the former musician was in the 1960s
band the grassroots
and ended up playing a bizarre alternate
universe interpretation of himself in
the office
the character was a flower child through
and through from the mung beans he
sprouted on a damp paper towel in his
desk drawer to his fake id machine
he sometimes forgot to do his job but
he'd find a way to cover
in this deleted scene creed behaved as
he never had before
competently we get to watch the man who
once toured with the likes of janus
joplin and the doors rock
out on a pennsylvania party boat playing
the electric guitar like he was born to
it
now i do quality assurance for a paper
company
as you can imagine uh drugs played a
part
had this been included it would have
been the only acknowledgment of the
history of the actor slash character
prior to the finale
in which he finally plays an acoustic
song the lateness of that reveal is a
lot of fun to watch but the deleted
scene shows the dunder mifflin crew
completely baffled at their colleague's
skill he might not be able to last more
than 90 seconds on a phone call but he
can play like he never left woodstock
the fake fire that led to stanley's
heart attack has become legendary on the
office it was a great opening scene from
the escalation of dwight's cigarette in
a trash can
to the moment angela's cat falls out of
the ceiling but social media has given
the clip new life
circulating everywhere from tumblr to
twitter stanley collapsing
is just the cherry on top of a strange
comedy sundae i'm gonna give him out to
about no don't give him out the mouth
for this
you're gonna swallow his tongue open
your mouth michael swan don't follow him
in the deleted scene michael buys a
portable defibrillator and you're fairly
certain he won't actually electrocute
someone but the office has never been a
show afraid to hurt its characters
after all someone already had a heart
attack and there was that episode all
about michael hitting meredith with his
car
but the funny comes from michael getting
into it with his arch nemesis in the
office
toby by the time michael makes his way
to the annex and asks for a handshake
from his greatest enemy
you're nearly convinced that michael
might just send a second employee to the
hospital
lucky for toby the prank is obvious and
michael doesn't succeed
but for a moment the audience is
perfectly suspended between horror and
hilarity
who could have imagined that phyllis
with her love of gaudy makeovers
charming handicrafts and overwhelming
perfume would have ended up so truly
bizarre
her marriage went from being a lovely
facet of the office park to the most
sexual relationship on the show
she took revenge on angela for crimes
committed in the name of party planning
and hey remember that time she revealed
that she gave up a child for adoption
and wondered if aaron might be that very
baby
phyllis's deaths were strange funny and
often pretty endearing
but in one deleted scene things take a
turn for the wildly morbid
phyllis straight up confesses to
manslaughter that she and bob
only narrowly got away with a crime she
isn't even able to convince herself into
dismissing
it's humor so dark that it makes sense
that it was cut but as a deleted scene
cast into the quasi-canon of the show
it's truly horrifically hilarious
before andy was in and out of love with
aaron before he was the boss
he was a fumbling salesman with nothing
but a cornell degree to his name
among the earliest hits he would take
was the moment he realized the young
woman he'd been seeing was
in fact an underage high schooler the
office pulled a bit more comedy from the
otherwise criminal situation in this
deleted scene
andy cartoonishly confronts his
girlfriend jim attempts to keep andy
from incriminating himself
and it becomes more and more clear just
how thoroughly she and her friends were
using him for access to the adult world
cutting this scene made the plotline
more focused on andy's failure to
establish himself in scranton
and made it less cringe-worthy sometimes
comedy comes from the stuff you don't
see
it makes sense that we don't get to see
much of michael splashing around in the
titular koi pond of this
sixth season episode especially when
much of the story
hinges on exactly how he fell in but a
deleted scene which shows the security
camera footage of the fall
and its aftermath reveals the whole
affair as a showcase of comedy greatness
corel shows off his slapstick chops to
an extent rarely seen in the show
somehow managing to drag the event into
an operatic odyssey
he repeatedly underestimates how far the
edge of the pond is as he slips and
stumbles
the fish are bewildered and as we learn
later in the episode
endangered by michael's prattfalls
michael
the custodian called again apparently a
coy has died
it's a fish and through it all the
security camera sweeps calmly back and
forth
there's just something perfectly absurd
about it and reminds us
of just how good physical comedy can be
jim and dwight's rivalry was a pillar of
the office from beginning to end
what made their tension so special was
the fact that dwight never stopped
believing himself to be the superior
man despite the many many times jim took
him down a peg
dwight is according to himself the true
authority in the office
an alpha male a genius and so entirely
perfect at being himself that his second
life virtual persona
just happened to also be a pennsylvanian
paper salesman
who owned and operated a small scale
beet farm it's dwight's ego which makes
this deleted scene so special
dwight's password is frodo because of
course it is
and then he changes it to gollum because
of course he does
a lesser show might have reduced jim to
a bully and dwight to the kicked around
patsy
but the cast and crew of the office knew
that dwight would never allow himself to
be reduced to such a cringing caricature
he's the volunteer sheriff and would
never show any kind of weakness around
his rival
but the audience roots for both of them
because no one's really getting hurt and
dwight and jim need each other to get
through their days at dunder mifflin
in this deleted opening scene dwight is
faced with the greatest dilemma of his
life
when authority is compromised who should
he obey he walks in to find his entire
desk
circled in police tape wondering what
happened his first instinct is to look
at jim who is the obvious prankster
on the one hand dwight believes himself
to be the greatest of all leaders
evidenced most dramatically by the time
in which he was manager
he became something of a dictator
commissioning portraits of himself for
the conference room and painting his
office as black as possible to
intimidate the employees that he
of course only ever refers to as
subordinates
and yet dwight is just as defined by his
servility
he never loses a chance to play
assistant to michael and all who fill
the managerial role after him
even if it comes at the cost of his
dignity to dwight there is no dignity
without hierarchy
essentially he becomes a robot faced
with a paradox
we often saw dwight reduced to
ridiculousness but rarely did we ever
get to see him play a part in it himself
season 4 starts off strong and not just
because jim and pam
finally decide to act on their feelings
that long-running plot line plays second
fiddle to the real star of the season
opener
the moment michael hits meredith with
his car the entire show came from that
moment
poised on the edge between horrifying
and hysterical that the office kept
sharpened to a wicked point
it became a tv legend what could ever
top michael scott's dunder mifflin
scranton meredith palmer memorial
celebrity
rabies awareness pro-am fun-run race for
the cure the deleted scene of everyone
visiting meredith in the hospital comes
about as close as anything could
it's a symphony of awkwardness a perfect
blend of these characters at their most
vivid
angela's bad attitude and kevin's blunt
narcissism are held barely in check by
michael
who of course is working overtime to
convince everyone that he is not at
fault here
the scene is everything that made these
characters so weird lovable
and ultimately unforgettable they might
not have wiped out rabies
but they cemented a place in our hearts
check out one of our newest videos right
here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one